Je suis sur le point de vous construire une maison une maison Je veux la
faire fondre jusqu'à DC vous vous mariez êtes-
vous sûr de cela par le pouvoir qui
m'est conféré par le District de Columbia Je
vous déclare maintenant mari et femme
ici ce que vous faites au lit  avec cette
femme, je suis sa femme, ce n'est pas bon ici
Richard Perry aimant être une
personne blanche et Mildred Jeter étant une
personne de couleur a cohabité illégalement son homme
et sa femme, je crois que c'est à peu près tout ce
qui pourrait aller jusqu'à la Cour
suprême
loin  dans son quartier l'état de
Virginie dira qu'il est injuste de
mettre au monde des enfants métis
dites à cette femme de venir ici
j'élèverai ma famille ici je me fiche de
ce qu'ils font ceux dont je peux m'occuper
toi je sais que rien à porter je sais que
nous avons des ennemis mais nous avons des
amis Tim
tu réalises que cette affaire pourrait modifier la
Constitution des États-Unis penses-tu
que tu perds nous pouvons utiliser une petite bataille
mais gagner la grande guerre y a-t-il quelque chose
tu voudrais que je dise au
Les juges de la Cour suprême des États-Unis ouais
disent au juge que j'aime ma femme